on doit tuer lui seul il est là alors il
a décidé de me re conquérir il est
entendu ce que j'ai dit à 2 millions
téléspectateurs et ce qui se passe à
vegas reste dans ton slip hanouna oui je
sais je sais et oui la reconquête est
parti j'ai une chanson pour vous encore
ouais style gospel vous dis j'aime bien
et a pris les couleurs de leurs ventes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors à leur attention petite chanson
pour reconquérir le coeur de cyril vous
êtes prêts owona
hanouna
oh tu veux montrer je te ferai les
cadeaux j'te ferai des cadeaux j'te
gratterai le dos ils grattent le dos à
leur revient baba
[Musique]
humain
saiger vache ça il a intérêt à bosser
plus pour demain sera face au bassin
torchon les paroles l'intention commence
à ce jeu m'a pris au mois sept minutes
droit nous n'achetons gratterai le 12
août offrait des cadeaux ballon il reste
rien du tout si serein il ratera
ciguatera la bague au doigt à mon pote
feria invités on se calme un petit peu
là comme ça mais la balle est essentiel
ville